that's kylie jenner slaying at every met
gala she's ever been to
but we won't be seeing her at this
year's event
the 24 year old kylie cosmetics founder
confirmed the news on instagram that she
will not be attending the 2021 soiree
writing in part i'm so sad i couldn't
make it this year i can't wait to see
all the looks
i'm obsessed with it so
yeah kylie also shared a montage of her
past looks and sweet moments from the
red carpet with her man travis scott
although kylie was in new york for
fashion week ahead of the event there's
no word on why the reality star decided
to forgo fashion's biggest night but a
source tells e.t kylie was considering
going this year and doing a gender
reveal but decided not to go and flew
back to los angeles instead
[Music]
earlier this month the beauty mogul
revealed she's expecting her second
child with travis after speculative
reports surfaced weeks prior
kylie shared this video announcement to
her instagram that showed sweet moments
of the pair and their three-year-old
daughter stormy are you ready to go to
mommy's doctor yeah
on sunday stormy's dad gave her a shout
out at the 2021 mtv vmas as the rapper
took home a moon man for best hip-hop
music video for his song franchise
although kylie was not in attendance she
did share a screenshot of her man
accepting his award
i first want to um thank god my mom
stormy
all the uh all the amazing fans out
there i love y'all so much we couldn't
do without y'all
um
to my label cactus jack epic records i
love you all so much um before i go i
just want to tell y'all love is the
biggest scene that we could ever hold
spread love and everything will be okay
[Music]